you know those accounts that post clips
of animation and list who the animator
was well 99% of them just go onto a
website called Saka goru and copy paste
the credit listed and while they may
have good intentions they don't always
know what they're doing and O that leads
to trouble the site's curated by fans
who Source credits from animator tweets
or by using their knowledge of styles to
make presumptions and while presumptions
can lead to mistakes any guesses are
tagged as such well one Twitter account
didn't pay attention to that and instead
pulled up a cut tagged with Ken Uka as
its presumed artist and pasted that onto
Twitter without the presume tag fast
forward a day and kenot tsuka seen it
quote tweeted it and said that not only
is it not his work but he wasn't even on
the movie moral of the story maybe check
the credits before making presumptions
and if you're going to rip info from the
site maybe also don't ignore and delete
the big presumed tag either